well let's get more on afghanistan now
and speak to a man who for a time worked
closely with donald trump on his foreign
policy i'm talking of course about john
bolton the former u.s national security
adviser and former u.s ambassador to the
united nations uh he joins us now from
washington thanks very much for being
with us uh this evening mr bolton
and now we've just heard
we've just said from the u.s state uh
department uh that they have six
thousand people fully protest away
processed and awaiting to board planes
in kabul airport
could you in 2001 could you ever have
imagined a scene
where the us would be entirely reliant
on the goodwill of the taliban
essentially to get people to planes to
evacuate
afghanistan
no i think the decision to withdrawal
american and nato forces was a
catastrophic mistake i think this is
sacrificed a strategic objective we've
had these last 20 years to prevent a
repetition of the 9 11 attacks i think
that strategic objective remains valid
and i'm very worried not just about
what's going to happen in afghanistan
i'm very worried about the implications
of this mistake for the u.s and the west
as a whole
as our adversaries uh analyze what what
we've done here i think we're going to
pay for this for a long time well i'd
like to come to come back to what you've
just said there about how that how the
us's adversaries might uh uh respond to
this but first i want to ask you whose
fault is what's happened in the last
week is it donald trump's or is it joe
biden's
well i think there are two questions
here the first question is was it
correct to withdrawal american forces i
think the answer to that was no but i
think both trump and biden wanted to do
that have wanted to do it for a long
time and really on that question their
opinions are like tweedledee and
tweedledum this is a trump biden
withdrawal the second question however
is the execution of the decision to
withdrawal
and that seven months into his
administration is entirely uh biden's
responsibility i think it's been bungled
terribly so it was already one major
mistake has taken on even greater
consequences because of how poorly this
whole effort has been conducted
i mean there is an argument that says
that a successful intervention in any in
any foreign country would surely create
the conditions for a withdrawal an
eventual withdrawal um looking at the
situation in afghanistan
it begs the question was there ever in
mind
the the intention to create the
conditions that would have allowed a
successful withdrawal
well i think the answer that question
always depends on the circumstances
you're facing uh american troops uh
entered germany in 1945 and we're still
there shall we get out
uh the the question is not ours alone to
answer the question is the nature of the
threat and uh i i believe we continued
to face the threat of uh of terrorist
attacks emanating from afghanistan and
giving the country back to taliban
almost inevitably it seems to me will
result in al-qaeda isis and other
terrorist groups taking privileged
sanctuary there
again and and that the risk of the
threats will go up it was always better
to conduct forward defense in
afghanistan than to fight in the streets
and skies over america that hasn't
changed except now that's probably where
we will have to fight and yet alongside
what you're talking about the military
uh side of things there's also an
intelligence failure here i mean it's
hard to believe that after 20 years uh
in afghanistan uh the u.s and its allies
could have been so wrong-footed by the
taliban to think that it wouldn't be
able to take over so quickly
is this the biggest uh intelligence
failure analysis or
failure of intelligence analysis since
the weapons of mass destruction failure
in the early 2000s
well i think it remains to be seen i
think we've certainly uh watched an
administration that's guilty of
congenital wishful thinking
uh completely misapprehend the nature of
the taliban threat
uh and i think uh this is where trump's
policy comes into play as well the
taliban have seen for a couple of years
now that they've had american presidents
who want to get out and you know the
taliban have long had a saying
you have the watches we have the time it
looks like the collapse occurred almost
overnight but taliban have been working
on this seeing trump's evident desire to
get out for quite some time this is the
culmination of it
any way you cut it mr bolton you were
one of the architects of that
intervention of these interventions in
iraq in afghanistan uh you were one of
those who who who supported intervention
how do you think it was allowed for the
taliban to be this powerful still 20
years later i mean that is whichever way
you spin it that is a failure of the
last 20 years
well i i don't agree with that if we
were still there if it were clear that
we had the will and the determination to
stay
uh i don't think taliban would have
taken over the country you know it's uh
it's like the keystone of an arch you
can build a very big impressive arch but
if you take the keystone out all you
have is a pile of rocks and when you
removed us intelligence for the afghan
army and security forces when you
removed u.s air cover and when you
remove the confidence that we the
british other nato members gave to them
uh it's not surprising to see this i
must say you we i obviously can't talk
about intelligence that i've seen
but i can tell you that when you deprive
an army of its morale
it doesn't matter what their equipment
or training or leadership is if they
fear they're going to lose and they fear
what the victors are going to do to them
they're going to melt away but what
about the nature of the investment the
nature of the intervention in
afghanistan had it not been a corrupt
government that had been put in place by
the u.s could we not have seen
a stronger defense against the taliban
could we not have seen it much harder
for the taliban to take over
stop
we did not put a corrupt government in
place corruption has existed in
afghanistan for a long time and here's a
news flash under the taliban corruption
will still exist
the u.s interest in the interest of nato
as a whole
was to prevent a terrorist takeover we
didn't have to reform afghanistan it was
probably a mistake to try
but the real question when you say but
all these things i'd like to just jump
in there because it is a line mr bolton
there's a line we hear how much risk we
hear a lot
we hear a lot
from the us that afghanistan was rife
with corruption but the us did nothing
to stop that corruption i'd just like to
i'd just like to talk about the last
speaker of the afghan parliament he's a
multi-millionaire and that is thanks to
monopoly contracts to provide fuel and
security to u.s forces at bagram the
main
air base the u.s certainly did nothing
to stop corruption
well that's simply not true but let me
ask you a question
uh and i wish you would let me finish so
that we could have this discussion how
much risk are you prepared to accept for
a terrorist attack on london
i mr bolton you know full well that i am
not in command of a country of any of
any sort this is not a question for me
to answer this is a question for our
political leaders to answer and this is
not how the interview works look by your
own measures of success which you have
claimed to be to stop the taliban to
stop al-qaeda from regaining a
capability to have a privileged
sanctuary from which they could plan and
direct attacks on countries like the u.s
by those very metrics the mission in
afghanistan failed i just would like to
know again how was it allowed to fail
it failed because of the decisions by
trump and biden to withdraw
for the last seven or eight years
uh we were muddling along quite well
without terrorist attacks the measure of
success is not whether afghanistan has
been turned into the switzerland of
central asia the issue is whether we are
protecting our civilian populations and
since the tragedy of september the 11th
there have been no terrorist attacks on
the united states conducted out of
afghanistan by al-qaeda or anything else
i call that a success
is the war on terror over
of course not as i indicated before
because of this uh
catastrophic decision to withdraw
we now face i would say the likelihood
of a return of the terrorist threat
uh and and that's why all of these
measures all these things you're talking
about about the corruption of afghan
society and and the faults of the afghan
people i'm very sorry for the afghan
people but let's be clear the united
states and nato did not go into
afghanistan to conduct charity uh for
the people there they've gained a lot of
collateral benefits
from our presence and and i'm glad that
they got them but we're there to protect
our owners as innocent civilians and we
have succeeded in doing that up until
this withdrawal
okay um i'll put it to another way there
may be
cambodia vietnam
the kurds in syria and now afghanistan
why is it that the u.s is such a bad
ally
well i think uh
that you know you're completely
mischaracterizing very very different
circumstances how did germany and japan
feel about america as an ally
these are
issues that you have to take under their
own circumstances and i'd be happy to
take them for as long as you want to
talk but to run up a list like that
as if that's a complete list of what
american policy it consisted of is a
total distortion of reality
you will admit though that it would be
hard for other potential allies to see
themselves i mean we keep hearing from
uh interpreters in afghanistan who say i
would not let my children uh work with
the us if they came back into
afghanistan because we know what that
means now but you'll work with them and
you'll be abandoned it would be easy to
see why future allies might not want to
work with the us um i just i because we
are running out of time
or is that you you know you said you
know what no okay you can
you can you absolutely can we're short
on time but please do well thank you
that's proves the point that we should
not have withdrawn
it is an enormous strategic setback for
the u.s what we've seen uh happening the
scenes we've seen unfolding uh over the
last couple of weeks in kabul um you
could say i mean i hate to draw
comparisons i know you don't like them
but it is as big almost a humiliation as
as vietnam was for the usa how
emboldened do you think and you touched
on this at the beginning of the
interview will the us says strategic
competitors i'm thinking of china i'm
thinking of russia how emboldened will
they be by what they've seen
well i think it's a mistake because it
says to our adversaries that the biden
administration is weak
uh and i don't think that's where the
american people are there are polls that
show just this weekend that when when
asked if if you knew that american
withdrawal would lead to taliban coming
back into power if american withdrawal
would lead to attacks from al qaeda
would you still favor withdrawal and the
answer is no
so this is a mistake in policy uh it's
it's always a tragedy when america makes
a mistake like this
but it does not i think
uh
determine inevitably what the future
will be that's why we have elections in
this country
john bolton uh former u.s national
security advisor thank you so much for
being with us here tonight on